in the name of Robert of the house
Baratheon the first of his name king of
the Andals and the first men lord of the
Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm I charge you to bring the King's
justice to the false Knight Gregor
Clegane and all those who shared in his
crimes what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight prediction video today I
want to talk about a handful of
characters that may or may not return
for one last season we all know people
like John Snow Daenerys Targaryen Cersei
Lannister and other main characters
still have very big parts to play in
this show but in this video I want to
discuss some of the other characters
that might not return at all most fans
want to know if we will ever see Daario
naharis again and most fans also want to
know if Jack and AG are still eyes apart
the play or not so today I want to talk
about these type of characters with the
cast as big as the one we have in Game
of Thrones it must be extremely
difficult to keep everyone involved in
the current story what the amount of
time they have decided to give
themselves the showrunners Dan and Dave
made the final decision to only film six
episodes for the final season and when
you have so many different storylines to
wrap up some characters end up being
forgotten or completely neglected I'm
afraid this might happen with the
characters I named in this video because
they probably don't have enough screen
time to fit them all in before I begin
let me remind everyone about the new
giveaway I have another set of the a
song of Ice and Fire books and I will be
giving them away in about two weeks from
today there is a link down below in the
description of the video and the link is
pinned at the top of the comments if you
would like to enter the giveaway just
click on one of those links good luck
now let's get started first I want to
start off the video with some of the
characters that don't seem to be coming
back at all a report recently came out
about Tycho's who has been the main
representative from the iron bank it
looks like we will not be seeing this
character ever again but that doesn't
mean the iron bank is completely gone
from the story even though Tycho's isn't
returning the iron bank could still be
involved in one of the storylines the
commander of the golden company could
always relay a message from the iron
bank since it was their money who hired
them in the first place we could also
hear from the iron bank through messages
via raven we
don't always need to see a character to
fill their impact on the plot and
something tells me this won't be the
last time we hear from the iron bank
it looks like Tycho's will survive but
he is simply being written off the
screen the next character I want to talk
about is Daario naharis the last time we
saw him was when Daenerys left him in
charge of marine right before she set
sail to Westeros ever since then fans
have wondered if Daario will make
another appearance a very popular theory
states Daario could be the commander of
the golden company but as of right now
this doesn't appear to be true HBO has
already filled this position with
another actor named Maher Chrisman
Daario will not be the leader of the
golden company and based on everything
else I have seen it doesn't look like
Daario is coming back to the screen
either another character that doesn't
seem to be returning his head Meera
thali the last mention of this
character's name was when Jaime and
Bronn were at the twins celebrating with
Walder Frey and miios back in the South
Congo killing my son by law wouldn't be
right did the family a bad name Walder
Frey told Jaime he had ed mirror put
back in the cells at the twins until
this day that is where he remains I was
hoping they would show Arya Stark
setting him free but they never did and
based on what the actor said himself we
probably won't be seeing him again
either when he was asked about his
character he said honestly I have no
idea
he's obviously somewhere in a prison
he's still around alive somewhere
they're pretty stingy with their
information meaning HBO and I've not
heard anything from them I feel like
they have so many stories to tie up
whether that's a story they'll want to
go back to I don't know I was hoping we
would see Ed Muir again just to get some
closure with this character but it
doesn't look like he will be appearing
on the screen HBO did cast two new
actors to play as Frey daughter so we
will see the twins again and perhaps we
could find out something about ed Mira
through a conversation but he has yet to
be seen during any of the filming so I
would not hold your breath on this one
for now I would say Edmure Tully is
still alive now let's talk about a fan
favorite known as Jack and agar
many fans will love to see him again but
as of right now this is still a big
unknown this is another character that
was not seen filming any scenes but he
was near the set of the dragon pit when
the majority of the main cast was there
as well
Jagan agar was seen taking some photos
with fans but why he was actually there
is still up for debate I happen to think
he was there as sort of a celebration
because of the show was coming to an end
but I would love it if he was actually
there to film some scenes in my opinion
I doubt we will ever see him again with
only six episodes left I think the only
characters we are likely to see again
are the characters of that war in last
season Arya Starks training is over and
Jack and agar splot from the books was
never set up in this show I would love
to see him pop back up an aria storyline
but I just don't think they have the
time but I cannot completely rule this
possibility out because you never know
what they could do for the final season
perhaps he does assist Aria in some way
or perhaps he would try to punish her
for the way she left the house of black
and white but when he smiled at Arya to
me that indicated he was content with
her leaving Braavos the way she did I
think if we see any more faceless men
activities it would be done through Arya
Starks character but I could be wrong
the great thing about Jack and gore is
you can never fully get rid of him
because one of the faceless men could
always wear his face and emulate his
voice I want to see this character again
but I would not bet money on him
returning the next character I want to
talk about is Artemis Tori burrows from
The Citadel he was featured in several
episodes last season but now that same
Walter Lee has left the Citadel you have
to wonder if we will ever see any scenes
or characters from there again I think
this one is possible although there
wasn't any reports of this character
returning to the show we know Sam was
trying to get the maesters to help with
the night king the archmaester did read
the letter from Winterfell and Sam did
confirm bran Starks report about the
others beyond the wall but unfortunately
they were not entirely convinced when
Sam left the Citadel he did take several
books and documents with him so there is
a very good chance Sam has enough
information with him that would allow
him to avoid reaching back out to anyone
Oldtown we also have brand Stark who can
look back in time so they might not need
any help finding any answers to the
current problems if that's the case then
we may have no reason to see the Citadel
ever again unless Sam would decide to go
back at the very end to finish his
studies but that doesn't seem likely
because he said he was tired of reading
about other men's achievements a few
ways I think we could see the art
semester being involved in a story again
as if Sam or bran have trouble figuring
out how to defeat the night king in that
case they may have to reach out to the
Citadel for help or if by some crazy
chance the knight King would happen to
make it that far south then we could see
him again but I do not think the knight
King will make it any further south than
King's Landing at the most I see him
being stopped away before then but
that's just my opinion as of right now
it looks like the archmaester will
survive the show because there have been
no reports of him being on set he could
be another character that is written off
there is another character that seems to
be in the same boat and that is little
Robin Arryn we haven't seen this
character in quite some time and I'm not
entirely sure if we will ever see him
again now that little fingers dead we
could potentially see songs of stark or
yon Royce take full control of the Vale
Army that way they don't have to bring
Robin back I used to think there was a
very good chance awns it could still
marry Robin Arryn but now I don't think
that's likely at all in fact after
everything she has been through songs I
may never want to get married again as
of right now I don't see them having any
reason to involve Robin in this story
the Vale army seems to still be at
Winterfell
along with yon Royce who has been one of
their leaders I suppose we could see
Robin again if the Vale would happen to
abandon the fight against the night King
or if the night King forced the Starks
out of their home then perhaps some of
them could take shelter at the Eyrie
but at the end of the day I really don't
think we need to see him again now I do
want to say it would be nice if they
could wrap up everyone's story in some
way because there are a lot of
characters that haven't had any official
closure but with only six episodes left
you got to be realistic there's only so
much they can do since they decided to
back them
sells into a corner by only filming a
handful of episodes when there are still
so many different characters alive I
would say Robin Arryn survives the show
but that's only by default because we
probably won't see him again now I want
to talk about one of the very few
characters that has somehow been able to
hold a job even when nothing but death
and destruction is all around his
current place of employment and that is
hot pie it's actually kind of crazy that
he is still alive considering he was
introduced all the way back in the first
season out of all the characters I am
mentioning in this video hot pie is
arguably the least important one he
doesn't have any high ranking titles
he's not a fighter he's not a scholar
and he has no connection to any kind of
magic however I think we have a better
chance of seeing him again next season
than any of the other characters I named
most of the characters I named in this
video aren't even in Westeros but
Hawkeye on the other hand is in a very
good location because we will see a lot
of travelling next season John Daenerys
and their teams are heading to
Winterfell as we speak after they fight
the night King they will have to travel
south again to take King's Landing from
Cersei depending on how they get all
their troops down there they could
travel right through the crossroads we
might even see Jaime Lannister stop here
in the very first episode since we know
he is travelling by land during all this
traveling you have to eat and sleep at
some point and the end of the crossroads
is the perfect place to do this not to
mention if Cersei would happen to send
the golden company north we could see
them stop here as well many different
scenarios can play out so I think there
is still a chance we could see hot pie
one last time now let's move on to
conveyor everyone's favorite red
priestess now this is another character
I could see returning to the show so far
she has had a very small part to play
but I think she could serve a bigger
purpose in the end game ever since
Melisandre is introductional into the
show we have known that she has been
preparing for the Great War to come
Melisandre was trying to help Stannis
create light bringer in one of her very
first scenes we also know Kim vara and
Melisandre both want to support Daenerys
Targaryen
Melisandre also wants to support Jon
Snow
but Jon doesn't ever want to see her in
the north again which ultimately led to
Melisandre leaving Westeros
Melisandre is currently on her way to
volantis and when she gets there I think
we could see a scene with her and can
Vera along with other followers of her
lore Melisandre should tell them about
Jon his resurrection and how he has come
in contact with the great other the
night king
she knows the night king is coming and
she even told Jon she can help him win
this war I think in order for her to do
this she had to go to volantis but for
what actual reason is still unknown it
could be to get kinvaras other
high-ranking members or even the fiery
hand which many people do believe the
reason why I think we could seek invar
again is mostly based on her one scene
during season six in my opinion the most
interesting thing about this scene was
what she said to Varys
she basically questioned him about his
loyalty to Daenerys then she reminded
him of the most traumatic event in his
life
which was when he was taken and cut by a
sorcerer when he was still a boy after
he was cut his parts were thrown into
the flames the flames turned blue
then Varys heard a voice that still
haunts him till this day my little birds
tell me that Stannis Baratheon has taken
up with the red priestess from Asshai
what of it
you probably don't entirely trust me
don't take it personally I don't
entirely trust myself and yet I have
seen things and heard things things you
have not things I wish I had known you
heard a voice call out from the flames
do you remember
should I tell you what the voice said
should I tell you the name of the one
who spoke
[Music]
why dick and vari mind him of this and
tell him she knew what the voice said
unless it was foreshadowing something to
come this is one of the main reasons why
I think Melisandre went to volantis I
think we could see Canberra again they
would obviously help fight the night
King but I also think they will play a
part in Varys his endgame we've all
known he's been afraid of magic and any
follower of relora for most of his life
every time he comes into contact with
the red priestess something very ominous
happens and I think if Varys does die a
red priestess will has something to do
with it I should also mention the
actress who plays Melisandre said
something very interesting about Varys
during a recent interview she said I
think he's not gonna make it but that's
my personal thought some things terrible
things have to happen in these last
seasons it'll probably be one of those
where he'll try to run from it but he'll
get it in the end he has known this ever
since the voice spoke out from the
flames out of all the characters on
whenever today which ones do you think
we could see one more time put all your
thoughts or questions down below in the
comment section I also want to let all
of you know how much I appreciate your
support my channel surpassed 300
thousand subscribers yesterday and I
can't even express how crazy that is
I really appreciate that and the same
goes for all of you on patreon your
contributions and your kind words always
give me motivation thanks again everyone
have a great day I will see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]